[Music]
Jodie Sweetin Christine Lakin and
Beverly Mitchell were amongst the
biggest child stars of the decade well
now they're all grown up and joining
forces when did you realize that you're
famous you know growing up in this
business you have weird experiences like
stalkers at very early age right you
know bodyguards you know with you when
you're 9 years old
you know things like that that you're
like oh this not everybody has this this
is okay this is strange
whatever happens childhood in the
Hollywood spotlight has brought the full
house starred together with Beverly
Mitchell from seventh heaven and
Christine Lakin from step-by-step in the
new comedy series Hollywood darlings
this is gonna be like a massage for your
soul well I was just looking for a
massage for my hands and my feet we
would get on set and we would just play
an improv but we wanted the show to feel
like a modern family wanted to feel like
a sitcom and I think it'd I think kind
of nailed what we wanted to do yeah and
the show isn't afraid to poke some fun
at the industry if anybody tells you
under 16 to have a nose job don't worry
about it doesn't work makes you look
strange you'll grow into your nose later
okay it's gonna be fine trust me there's
so much going on in your personal lives
and and professional I mean Jodi how you
doing crates Jody mum about her split
from fiancé Justin Hodak but says
thankfully she's on the mend after
surgery for multiple fractures after a
freak accident involving climbing a
fence retrieving her daughter's toy I
finally started walking last week so you
know getting to do all the press stuff
and everything it's going really well
Beverly who played Jessica Biel's
younger sister for 10 years says she's
still very close to Jessica and Justin
Timberlake they're not Jesse and Justin
to any of the people who I am with just
because we've been around for like 20
years
[Music]